i've talked to you about grades i have a
lot of questions about grace
first of all there was some mix-up this
week because people thought you guys
were getting back into production but
you're not getting back into production
do you have any sort of timeline what
are those conversations like right now
about when you could go back to filming
it seems like um september
seems like in about a month uh okay
september right now
again you know uh we were trying to end
of august and then it pushed so we're
you know um our producers are all
rapidly trying to implement all of these
protocols to keep keep everybody safe
we're obviously going to be tested
multiple times a week and sort of
separated in zones we're gonna have a
lot less personnel on set
um we're gonna be wearing full ppe of
course
as we're gonna take place in coronavirus
on the show when we start the season so
all of our actors will be justifiably uh
protected
um so it works both ways um
and um and yeah we'll we'll see it's a
new world we're uniquely lucky that we
get to wear ppe
because we play doctors so for other
shows that aren't in the doctor world
um i really feel for them because that's
an added challenge even more that they
have to face
but i'm really hoping that we can figure
it out and keep producing this amazing
show that so many fans love to watch
and there's been no shortage of uh
incredible stories that have been going
on during this time you know both within
the hospital walls
and also on the streets of a lot of
cities um protesting so
we hope to tell all those stories this
season
have you received any of the season 17
scripts yet like do you know where
things are gonna
not no no i really feel for the writers
and the writers guild
um this year writers are very
compromised because they have to think
about the produce ability
of what they're writing right it's like
okay i created this great scene but can
we shoot it
you know are we able to safely shoot
this scenario okay
you know it's a great scene but that
means we're gonna have to have 10 people
there and then
no it's not going to work we're not
going to be able to safely do that and
it's going to expose
no sorry so when the writers are having
to constantly go back to the drawing
board and
and really um it's really kind of
tightening
uh their their freedom in terms of what
they can write so
um i really feel for them you mentioned
the
pandemic episodes or episode and i know
that chris has talked about that a
little bit
how do you think the luca would fare in
an episode or an episode
like that i kind of think he thrives in
chaos
and um he's certainly proved that in the
past seasons that you know when there's
a lot going on he really
steps up so i i think this is going to
be
obviously a very stressful situation but
i think an exciting one where i think he
can really shine and then thrive
do you know anything about the direction
that that episode is going to go you
said it could be at the very beginning
of season 17.
we're going to start the season about a
month and a half into uh
full coven so it's gonna take place
um you know a little bit beyond where we
left off at the last
uh season so we might have some
flashbacks we might have some things
where we're referencing last season just
to kind of give us some context leading
up
but we are going to have a little bit of
a leap when we start this season in
terms of time we're not picking up
right where we left off mackie said
she'll call us if there are any changes
[Music]
i can't
[Music]
okay okay well then i have a lot of
questions about that because
deluca left off and i'm a little bit
worried for his mental state but you
also mentioned
possibly a protest episode or covering
the protests
on the show how do you see that i'm just
speculating at this point
all the writers and producers have said
you know they're very interested in
telling the stories of
you know everything that's been going on
with black lives matter movement
during during this time and it's
certainly something that they're you
know whether it's the first episode or
the second or the
you know i don't know where it's going
to land but they're very interested in
definitely telling
those stories well let's talk about
deluca a little bit because when he
didn't leave off
i mean he sort of saved the day when it
came to richard and that cobalt's hip
but a lot of people were very worried
about his
mental state um you mentioned the time
jump so i'm curious where his mental
state could be
is that going to be explored more in
season 17
yeah i'm curious too with you i think
it's definitely going to be continued to
be explored
um you know that was a big build up to
that storyline that we had talked about
you know two years ago slowly sort of
ramp up to two buildings
this storyline for for de luca so i
think you know where we ended even
though it's not
exactly where we wanted to end last
season
um i think there would have been a
little bit more resolve have we not been
shut down
um we're gonna have to play that in in
this season um
so yeah chris krista had mentioned
that so there were four episodes that
were kind of left
on the cutting room floor they were
never aired and she mentioned
there might be rewrites they might need
some of that material
do you have an update on on that so we
would hate to just kind of throw it away
so i think
we might uh be using it as sort of
context to kind of catch us
up to where we are currently when we
start the season to kind of bring us up
uh to to speed um it's kind of sprinkled
throughout
yeah but again that's just you know
speculating at this point i i don't know
what they're you know every day
you know they're probably having new new
guidelines in place and so it's
it's a challenging thing to start i'm
sure you saw the news that richard blood
was
up to the series regularly yeah so happy
for him
we love uh it means a lot more mick
widow though potentially so what does
that mean for the love triangle between
meredith and deluca
and him yeah well i think you know
in the beginning um from
just you know um the outside sort of
viewer mentality watching the show i i
think it was clear that
you know he was having a hard time uh
getting his foot in the door
of that triangle um uh richard's
character
and uh but by the end of it because of
deluca's mental health he he did really
you know
uh not do great favors for himself or
for meredith in terms of their
their relationship leaving richard
to be open to be much more desirable and
stable and
more of a compatible partner so i think
you know
this season will probably
feature a lot of um deluca trying to
make up maybe for
his wrongs things he said things he did
when he was you know unstable
meredith having to maybe reconcile that
or not
um and and richard's character trying to
continue to pursue uh meredith so um
i think it's something that we still are
interested in that's why
you know they updated him to the series
regular so we could really
have him around for a while and really
tell that story and not have to tell it
in a short time but really
have the time of the of a season or so
to tell that
we love a grey love triangle
it's a patented technique grey's anatomy
um where do you think meredith's head is
at and do you think
meredith and deruka could be end game
i think they definitely have a great
compatibility i definitely think they
have a lot of
chemistry uh they're fun to watch and
i've been with people who are
my opposite but you're attracted because
of that and sort of you sort of
complement each other
or or you know fill in each other's gaps
in a way
so i think they are kind of yin and yang
in the sense that they're in different
places in their lives
um they've had different experiences in
their lives and these are the things
that help to kind of complete each other
so
um i i i think that they
they have a good shot but i don't know
where where
you know the future will lead you guys
are going into season 17 which is
an amazing accomplishment do you ever
think about
you know the final season do you guys
talk about that i put my foot in my
mouth so many times over the years
i don't know i don't know what this is
gonna you know
i think this year is gonna be sort of a
test run in in terms of like can we
actually do this show like can we
actually shoot this
show safely like were we able to get
through a season how many challenges
were there
how much did it cost us and all those
kinds of things and i think
that's going to ultimately you know make
a
a re-evaluation at the end of the year
and say like dude
can we even do this again you know what
i mean so
i think the studio and everyone wants us
to make it forever because it's so
beloved
uh but uh i i really don't know how long
it could go on at this point with with
code and everything
if it were up to you though would you
would you play dulutha for
as long as they wanted you to i love
playing de luca
as long as i was open to doing other
projects as well then then yes
definitely i am very
very proud of my duluth character i want
to commend you because you're using your
platform
for something really nice you're doing
this virtual
festival and it benefits my friend's
place um
which helps homeless teens so kind of
talk about
why you wanted to host this and be a
part of this and why it's
important to you um so
every year my friend's place for those
of you who don't know is a drop-in
resource center for homeless youth in
los angeles we
serve ages 12 to 25 as well as their
children
as well as their dogs and their cats
but because when this crisis hit um
a it forced a lot of people who were on
the line
into homelessness my friends placed a
very very noble thing and they lifted
their age bracket and started welcoming
anyone of any age
to come to their doors because they
recognize that you know they need to
work with other organizations
to make sure everybody out there was uh
getting
uh what they needed so i really
recommend them for that you've worked
with them for a while now right like
you've done
about five years now how will this event
be different i mean obviously it's
virtual
we decided to do a five day long summer
festival where each day of the five days
we have something that's easy an hour
you jump in you jump out very accessible
and then you can go about your day
and it's all to raise money for homeless
youth so um
uh we're kicking it off this sunday
uh august 9th uh was standing together
it's our benefit concert so we got
all kinds of artists like jojo mario
kenzie ziegler and a lot more
it's free you just tune in to um
all of my friends places uh streaming
platforms on youtube facebook
instagram and you can stream it live for
free and you get to see all these
amazing artists that you love sing and
perform so that's pretty cool
it's on all of my socials you can see it
mfp summerfest.gifsmart.com
that's where you can sort of purchase or
sign up for all these different
workshops even though it's a time of
need so we all
obviously understand but if there's
anything that any family can spare we
would really really greatly appreciate